[Music]
today's question comes from alex in
chattanooga my father-in-law wants to
take the whole family seven adults four
kids to scotland in 2024. his scheme is
to pay for the air tickets with american
express credit card points he has
ordered cards for his three daughters
and wants them to pay for everything in
their life with them and pay him back on
a weekly or monthly basis not sure of
that detail yet he has already decided
this and the cards are in the mail
apparently he needs about one million
points to get all the tickets for free i
know this is a horrific idea i don't
know how to tell him no on this can we
just before we get into this it's kind
of a great idea like brilliant i see
this guy he's was like in a in an ihop
and he was like wait a minute
and then he's like uh had a napkin and
started doing the math it was like
i could take my whole family oh it needs
a million points oh man's a million
points this is like when i was at chuck
e cheese and i was like okay i need 40
000 tickets to get the boombox and so
i'd spend like 20 bucks 30 bucks and i'd
end up with like 400 tickets and they
gave you like a little sticky hand yep
and like a pack of gum and so with
eighteen thousand dollars i could get
that boom box up there with forty
thousand huh okay so uh he's asking i
don't know how to tell him no it's a
father-in-law it's a it's messy it's a
little bit of a different relationship
all right so
um anytime somebody's asking me george
how do i tell somebody no on this
um
we always practice
say repeat after me
no thank you
and then they'll look at me like i'm
kind of an idiot and then they'll say no
thank you and i'll be like that look at
that you did that right you did it so
here's what we have here we have a
father-in-law who loves his family
and he wants to do a really cool thing i
would even go as far to read into this
story is that there's something in their
family lineage in scotland right maybe
it's we're going to go back and see
where great great great great
grandparents lived or something
the whole idea here is pretty cool and
the father-in-law um wants to honor
everybody we're going to do this and
father-in-law looks in the bank account
and says i can't pay for 11 people to go
for a week to scotland fair enough very
few father-in-laws could do that
but he figured out a plan um
it's just that the plan as as alex
writes is a horrific idea right um
george walk through why is this a
terrible idea i've got my own opinion on
it but go ahead well number one he's
apparently forcing his daughters to
use credit cards to fund their life in
order to get these points and so i look
at it logically i look at the goal right
the goal is scotland 2024 for 11 people
and i go okay how much is that gonna
cost so then i go okay we have two years
to save up let's say it's three thousand
dollars a person then i go okay daughter
number one could you save up three
thousand dollars in the next two years
what would that take to do that with
cash
and i guarantee you it's a lot easier
than the scheme of hoping you have
enough points and by two years from now
let's hope american express hasn't
changed their program and what those
points are actually valued at and what
the blackout dates are and which
airlines and places you can fly to and
worse nightmare worse built into this is
hey honey you owe me 49. hey honey you
owe me 706 dollars and what happens when
they can't pay because they overspent to
trying to help dad get as many points as
possible or they have a they have a 700
costco bill and they swipe it and then
all of a sudden the transmission falls
out and they got to fix that and now
dad's like wait a minute guys i gotta i
need my
but john there was six percent
points
if you shop online at this specific
retailer so that's why i spent a
thousand dollars gotcha in order to get
the six percent instead of the four
points i needed 111 pairs of banana
republic socks so that i could get this
this is the game we're playing now the
numbers here are outrageous a million
points if anything regardless of what we
don't know what these points are worth
so great so look at bitcoin all right
here's my problem with it okay and you
know i've talked about this just hanging
out
um let's say this works perfectly
let's say
the family they're all in they come up
with a foolproof system
we are going to every week we're going
to write data check for the money that
we spent we're going to spend anyway
we're going to spend this money anyway
we had to buy groceries anyway we had to
pay for rent anyway we had to do all
these things anyway we just threw on
this
american express card and then we wrote
dad a check instead of writing it to um
our rent or to our light bill or
whatever everything works out perfectly
and the family takes a 100
free trip to scotland in 2024 it all
works
here's what got me out of this system
um because i'm somebody who
used points
and we paid it off every month it never
affected my family other than i was
quote unquote winning
and it was a light bulb moment for me
when i realized oh this credit card
company's not my friend they're not just
giving me free flights in hotels because
they like me and they're like you've
been so good to us bro we're gonna be
good that's not how they work
then i realized that there's a single
mom with three kids trying to figure out
she can put gas in the car because it's
tripled in price
and she can't figure it out she's got to
swipe this card and it's got a 500 limit
and she's having to balance that card
with another one with a 250 limit and
she's paying for my flight
and i'm not going to be a part of a
system that preys on people who can't
make their payments or who found
themselves suddenly a single mom like
the last caller or who's living in a
city and all of a sudden rents tripled
i'm not going to go to scotland for free
on the backs of those men and women who
are trying to scratch and claw their way
through life i'm opting out of a corrupt
system that preys on people who have
less than or who are struggling i'm not
gonna play
i couldn't enjoy a trip to scotland that
i got for free knowing that it was paid
for by people who can't like who are
struggling yeah right
or who have not don't have enough
control in their life or who use um
who use
shopping as some form of medication or
some sort of anxiety relief from trauma
i'm not gonna play that game i'm opting
i'd rather pay for my trip to scotland
i'd rather tell my family i want to do
this cool thing like you mentioned
earlier in two years can we all save up
can we all be a part of this i'd rather
that than this pretend thing like i'm
taking this all for free you all just do
chores for me for the next two years
yeah you do chores for me for the next
two years and then we're all going for
free i'm just not playing that game so
it's not so it's more of a it's a heart
if you truly believe it's free
then their marketing is working very
very well that's right or that they're
friends with you that's amazing because
what's gonna take truthfully they're
gonna have to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars on those cards over
the next two years in order to get their
million points and even if you were
going to do it anyway
don't play in a system that preys on
other people just don't man not worth it
yeah so just save up so give yourself
some passion here here's the here's the
the truth before we pass this on
your father-in-law comes to you and says
hey um this is what we're doing this is
how we're doing it
the conversation um is probably
again uh me and a friend of mine argue
on this but
i think your wife is the one or your hus
i don't know if alex is uh man or woman
but whoever is this the the direct child
of this father-in-law sits down and says
hey
i don't play with credit cards i don't
participate in this game you let me know
how much the tickets cost and i'll let
you know if we can afford our family's
ability to go and we will put in the
cash on this trip but i don't
participate in this and it might be are
you come on it's all figured out it's
all cool that's great man i just don't i
don't play in that game and if your
father-in-law doesn't respect your
family's boundaries in that way this
trip to scotland's gonna be a pretty
awful adventure so you're you've opted
out thank goodness you avoided a pretty
disastrous trip together right yeah i
only see the one of two ways either
father-in-law goes hey i want to gift
this to you guys with no strings
attached or hey i'd love to go on this
trip let me know if you guys can make it
and if we can afford it there you go but
this weird in-between of you got to play
by my rules and sign up for this credit
card and pay me back every month for
everything you that creates a very
different dynamic in the relationship
yeah it
it just it just sounds like i've come up
with a great idea you just do uh chores
for me for a long time it reminds me the
call dave took where he a guy said hey i
want to buy a pay phone for the house
and everyone puts quarters in it and
then i get all the money and i would get
free phones and dave's like don't you
have to pay for like you know the phone
line like the air that the phone
and the guy was like oh i didn't think
about that dang it i thought i scammed
the system
and oh boy
good job yeah